all right everybody time to settle down
get back in your seats please because we
have
more films to show you and that's the
live action nominees and after we screen
them
uh we will have another panel so thanks
and
enjoy the next nominees
you don't need me to tell you what this
means to the parish to father o'toole
to father hanley to your parents to your
school to just about everyone you have
ever met in your life
but i want you to forget about all that
and i want you to ask yourself this one
question
what does it mean to you you
sitting there what
does it mean to you
owen for 20 years i was blue in the face
telling boys that the sanctus bell is an
instrument not a bloody panic alarm you
can't just pick it up and jingle
jangle like a flipping fire engine
howling through town
it's all one movement lift and ring
lift and ring the first spell should
peel at the end of the upswing
you are a natural son
i have seen parishioners shiver with the
clarity of your ring
show them make them feel it
finbar pound for pound you are the best
communion man in leinster right now
maybe ireland you have the perfect hold
with a communion pattern
an inch and a half under the chin every
time
the only thing i'll say to you boy is
don't
get too built up i've seen it happen
until ads in big masses before
wandering around on the altar like
cattle hipped up on angel dust
cool it now you and simon are my offer
tree and tabernacle squad today now lads
as i have said
time and time again the tabernacle
that is our goal mouth it is our six
yard box
you have got to keep your composure
around it don't let me see
that mouth hanging open again simon it's
the flesh and blood of our savior he's
taking out of there
not a hug a ham
now we all know you're in here on a wild
card zone
now you say what happened two weeks ago
was an accident
the jury is still out on that one but i
the parish really needs you to come in
for us today
and if you keep a clean sheet you will
earn yourself
guaranteed first team selection for
known mass on sundays
and if you don't come in well then
you're pretty much finished in this town
are you with me boy yes mr quinn
i'm with you
that's the lead all right on your feet
let's see some grace some vision
anticipate
keep a yard on the pace of the service
remember if the archbishop is thinking
it
we're already doing it go out there
and have the mass of your lives
it's good
okay
hasho
little boy
did you see a little boy like this
raju
this is
do you have a picture of your son
facing
we call you there if we have something
found us
foreign
foreign
mr fisher
i'm sorry even my employees don't know
anything
is there something i can do just go back
to your place
i'm sure he'll turn up again
is
they're not in
hello can i help you
hello mary
jemima
jesus christ
oh [ __ ]
you haven't changed a bit
this is my daughter patricia
call me pat it's nice to meet you
i know it feels like a lifetime
where is he
paddy no he's at the shore
i'll go get him
that's him in the orange coat
yeah putty that's all it's your house
that's not mary pointing out a scissor
you can't see anything
nothing wrong with my eyes is that other
woman filming
she is she is filming
shouldn't be the dull investigators huh
she's been having us away
that's what cheese doing [ __ ] me it has
a dull investigator
couldn't be they wouldn't be that stupid
i think we'd go towards him
not that stupid indeed it just caught us
working on camera
your wife turned us in so we're too far
away to be recognized
do you ever hear a zoom cameras she
can't hear us
i'll go get him but no mary um i go i
want to surprise him
well they're coming over that can't be
the dole
not waiting around to find dude too far
away they'll never catch us
come on yeah slow down don't be giving
the game away for running
where are they going
thanked up stop
dad look hi could you do us a favor
oh my god
i've brought in a horse
what is that let's say the timeline i've
been traveling along
oh cool where have you been so far
oh well you know
yesterday what
it's complicated what does 9 a.m dry
cleaner mean
okay you know i've been working on this
idea non-stop for a long time
of course and this week i could tell i
was getting really close which
is why i never came back to the
apartment finally
super late tuesday night i cracked it
so i was planning on doing my first real
trip wednesday morning ancient rome
exactly it's always been the dream
so i went to the dry cleaners that
morning to pick up my nice shirt you
know so i could look
presentable for photos and whatnot and
um
the dude at the dry cleaners was a real
okay hello sir
ah how are you yes
now he told me the shirt was gonna be
ready by monday
and it wasn't now this was wednesday
and uh he wasn't even cool about it
that's it
not really so i flipped out on him
what's the point of tickets
i don't know if it was like a lack of
sleep but i really
went off bad no you
why so
so when i came back here i felt so awful
about how i treated the guy
i went back in time to do it over again
how'd that go finally got it right after
a few tries
a few tries oh it's harder than you'd
think why the shirt is never ready
i'm sorry look no matter how many times
i go back in time the shirt is never
ready you know even though he told me it
was gonna be ready back in the original
timeline seriously what is this play
so you built a time machine and you've
been traveling around yesterday
i was just trying to change my reaction
to the situation
i'm sorry i can i just it's okay
it's just a shirt so
what's debbie 9 30 i ran into debbie on
the way back here
oh god
now
not
so
faking
uh
so
yes
foreign
so
yes
foreign
so
can we have the uh there we go can we
have the nominees for the live-action
films please come up
give them a big round of applause
congratulations thanks hi
nice to meet you hi congratulations
thank you very much
hi nice to meet you hi nice to meet you
hi nice to meet you
yep just find your names here
um so a fantastic
group of films and i'm just going to
kind of ask a general question to all of
you
why did you choose to make a short film
do you feel the discipline of brevity uh
forced good
choices the money we did it for the
money
good you'll go far in this town
well we uh terry my dad who
wrote and directed this had been trying
oh you're
mike isn't mine okay there we go
here try mine for a little bit okay
thanks um basically uh this was
our movie the shore was based on a true
story that my dad had heard from his
uncle
and he'd been trying to work it into any
number of scripts
for years i'm i'm kind of say he'd made
hotel rwanda and in the name of the
father and
there's always like a horse scene being
squished into the middle of it so
this was finally the opportunity for him
to just do justice to that story and not
try and uh put it in somewhere else
right well uh
yeah um what about you
uh we we were planning on buying an
apartment uh in new york city and
uh after our wedding and we're both
working
in tv and some reality
shows cooking shows and thought time
freak by the way
yeah i gotta introduce you guys if we
put the money down on
uh on an apartment we're gonna be really
tied to whatever job
uh we have to take and so gigi very
wisely
said let's make a film instead of buying
an apartment
and so uh we didn't have enough money to
make a feature
yeah right it was gonna be a small
apartment it's gonna be that size
apartment
great um so uh uh uh halvar
uh who did uh tuba atlantic what about
you
well uh it was the diploma film
of the school so if i didn't do it i
would have failed
and the king in the king and country
would hunt me
and not give me a diploma of
finishing three years of film school so
we were destined
to make this film uh we had to uh
the social democratic nation of norway
decided that we should make a
a film so that's how films are made in
norway you just get a mail a letter
and the king says you have to make a
film and then you say yes
sir no it wasn't like that but uh
it was almost it it's a fun
it's a final project that you do on the
film
at the norwegian film school and
everybody's divided into
uh six different groups uh one director
one producer
and it is like a mayhem uh where
you are trying to the directors have a
story or
idea and you're trying to flirt with the
producers and the writers to
to work with your film so i was like
and then the two most beautiful girls at
a school the producer and writer
just got into my sports car and wow
that's how we took off
oh man you're gonna have a great career
um what about uh you uh eamer o'cain
um uh uh you're peter wasn't able to
make it tonight
no but i'll be peppering you with all
the annoying questions
um it's actually pretty much exactly the
same as your story
no um we basically uh this is pentecost
pentecost uh peter had an idea i had a
um an image of a particular scene it's
the scene in the in the
center of the film um which is
set in the sacristy in the church and
he kind of having been an altar boy
himself
and he kind of remembered that feeling
of kind of entering this arena of such
high stakes where
everybody is watching and just the risks
are so high
and he kind of he you know
compared that to the feeling in the
in a sports kind of arena and getting
ready
for a big game so that's where the idea
started from and
the more he kind of scratched away at
that idea he felt that it would
fit in really well in the short film
genre
right so raju with
max zala and stefan gieron
what about you guys uh well we were
bound to make a short movie
uh due to our university as well and
these films are
have to have 25 minutes of of of length
so
we had no other chance but then again it
was a big challenge to
to take to take the issue the topic to
take our story and condense it to
to to to the very to the very core of it
and to make it a 25-minute short film
right so is is uh when did you learn i
mean
this is a real problem right uh when did
you learn about that
well um um we were by the way i'm max
with stefan
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry um
no we heard about that we were looking
for a thesis a topic for our thesis film
from film school uh uh
almost two years ago and there was this
earthquake in 80 and uh
children got stolen out of that country
to put them into foreign
families so um we started research on
the topic and found out about this
global
big thing do they do they go do they
pick certain children that are more
appealing looking or i mean do they
choose i mean it seems like they're you
know
how would you how how would you pick
which child to steal i mean
there must be some because there's
millions of
actual homeless kids aren't there it's a
really good question actually it's uh
i mean there's certain ways different
ways to get those children sometimes
actually it is like
parents say well we would love to have
like
you know a bright one you know they give
them a list of traits
yeah so there are cases like that but
not always you know
like in this case the the foreign
couple doesn't know that they're
adopting an ideal child so
you know so that's like one of those
child children
um that just gets stolen from from poor
families
around the big cities uh who and then
the those families who have the money
to you know to to look for the children
so they just lost
right wow uh it was amazing um
so this the shore um since
your uh father is
such an accomplished uh playwright and
screenwriter and director
what is the itch that only a shorter
film can scratch
um well basically doing that stuff all
the time so
yeah i think it was a chance to talk
about reconciliation in northern ireland
in a way that was
sort of specific there isn't a lot of
media that sort of reflects right now
where this amazing reconciliation has
taken place
and not just on a national level but
actually every day
people reconnecting and that's sort of a
story that you can kind of explore
really beautifully
in a specific way rather than trying to
to make it into a feature and so
there's a legacy of irish short films
and
he was kind of excited to work in that
and
it's funny because even though he's sort
of established it was his first short
film ever
and it has all of its own constraints i
mean he'd also never made a movie in
northern ireland
so it's his first time working at home
and you know we shot in our backyard we
just used all family so it's kind of a
funny journey for us because this is
as close to a home yeah that's our house
so it's like this is a home movie
i mean my aunt did the costumes my mom
cooked the food
so to be here is really strange and at
the same time
you know terry may be established as a
filmmaker but i'm sure a lot of the
people here have made lots of short
films
and so there were so many times when we
were going and watching short films
to find out how this medium works
yeah it's great it kind of forces you to
get right to the point right
very much there's no uh there's no kind
of luxury
wonderful um so um andrew
yes sir um what about
being a both a master of time and a
surreal squanderer of it is personal
i mean yeah i had to took a lot of work
to get into the head space of a erotic
character like
that just try to create a character and
guess what he'd be like you know
and uh i think we got it close
i mean is there something about the
medium of film that that make because
you are dealing with
time you know uh that that seem like a
natural for this
you know i i was uh honestly it is the
regret that was uh that was fun to play
with
and it was it was that idea and
um i think we kind of avoided the
mind-bending topic of time travel by
kind of making it about
regret and friendship and helping a
friend and one friend being in a really
bad spot was sort of the primary
focus of it we had the two actors over
for dinner the night before we started
rehearsal and
gigi made dinner we had wine and they
asked me all sorts of time
travel questions well but what if this
and that and i like to think i can
answer
almost anything that comes um my way and
then at the end of the night i said okay
so that's it that's the last time travel
conversation we're gonna have for the
rest of the time
it's a really naughty subject a lot of
filmmakers avoid it because it's a can
of worms that cannot be closed
and um you know was it a challenge to
keep it simple
i mean yeah i mean you just have to cut
it off at a certain point you have to i
mean you you just
for me you never got past 2 30 yeah
because 2 30 blew my mind and
12 minutes blew my mind too which is why
it's 11. no uh it's i think it's
it's finding a place where you are
answering questions you have to answer
questions and where you're not
answering questions that aren't asked
that's the biggest thing because there
are a bunch that aren't that you could
ask
or you could answer and they'd be like
well i didn't care about that so you
have to draw a line somewhere you know
yeah
but that always bothered me in star wars
when they go uh
hold your fire and and uh there's no
life forms aboard
like like they wouldn't blow it up
anyway just like standard operational or
or
there literally is one not to bag on
star wars but there is one in episode
one where it's like literally
there's another thing we have to worry
about and then they say why they don't
have to worry about the thing and i
always say i don't think i was worrying
about that
until it happened yeah right well i
never would have asked the question
about the life forms you know
exactly like well you could have skipped
that and well anyway fine
yeah i will raise your geek and uh
oh man sorry oh yeah sorry about that
special time yeah
sorry you all had to see that
um so uh um
tuba atlantic uh why do you hate
seagulls
i don't hate seagulls i i kind of grew
up with them so they
are my three thousand cousins uh
but at some point you kind of hate your
cousins too
uh they're much older than you they are
taller than you
and you know the santa monica uh
seagulls that are
really cute and small and they just come
in
herds of five right in norway they come
like
they they come like british spits fire
squadrons
they are big bulky like uh like memphis
belts
i mean they have wingspans of five
meters they [ __ ] all over you
and i mean the the population is
so increasingly fast growing in norway
right uh my fresh water which is
actually named by a guy
called halwar which is my name uh they
are polluting it by
[ __ ] in it wow they are [ __ ] in
my water
so so i kind of i just
gave uh the actor the the possibility
edward who is here now the possibility
to
uh get my anger through a big
german machine gun that's fantastic
i'd say the revenge is felt deeply
where did the idea come from what
sparked it
well i i grew up by the ocean
by the west coast of norway and i
remember my
my grandfather he he kind of took
long walks with me he never said
anything which most norwegians never do
they don't say anything but my
grandfather
opened his mouth and a mouth and he
just well before that he just pointed
again towards the west over the atlantic
and he just said
there liv there is my brother and
his brother was living in new jersey
they were having constantly
uh they were talking to each other on on
the phone but
a lot of norwegian immigrated to america
finding like there was no jobs in norway
and and
so he really missed his brother uh
and i grew up with a brother that was
older than me that i really looked up to
and when i was growing up i
i kind of like i kind of
this brother the love between brothers
have been very
special for me and especially
the distance you have to travel
to see the ones you love uh
so that is kind of the idea the the very
because tube atlantic is very personal
uh
the idea actually came through
like a sketchbook i kind of draw the
earth
and two old guys on each side and a big
tuba
so i mean the the basic idea of it was
very old when i kind of tried to pitched
it
uh i just had music and those two
drawings uh
to kind of with my producer and
script artist yeah yeah
look at those drawings yeah that was
very international speak by the way you
know
um so peter mcdonald
uh the writer director is known
primarily as a an actor
he is yes yeah and has he always wanted
to direct or did his acting
spark his interest um i think he's
always had an
interest particularly in in writing and
but this is really his first funded
short film
and when when we first met um i was
explaining to him the process of
applying for funding to the irish film
board and saying you know what part of
you'll have to
you know get me your showreel and he was
like my what
so he he quickly went off and made a
short film
and which actually did very well in its
own right but that was
that was the his showreel for for
getting pentecost funded
and so yeah basically his his background
unfortunately that's the reason he can't
be here
um tonight uh which he regrets hugely
but he's
finishing uh a tv series in ireland at
the moment
well that's a good reason i think we'll
accept it right yeah
um is there something particularly uh
irish about competing religions
you know church versus soccer
is there i i think you could probably
safely say yes yeah well they both
happen on a sunday
and so you've got to prioritize right
um